pour lui
[Applaudissements]
il
quand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous remontez chez vous sur twitter sur
hbo book
attention les nids tu peux pas te côté
valérie que le champion a donné note
déjà - foyer de les notes mois la fetwa
c'est en réalité en neuf
selon la note que valérie bénaïm se le
rappelle pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
dans ce concours
nous sommes en direct la note de valérie
bénaïm et consultative qui t'a fait
d'accord donc en fait les chéris voici
le premier danseur on va aller crescendo
j'ai classé pour moi le du moins bon
danseur au meilleur danseur au mois le
mois bon danseur d'authie pmp à mon avis
c'est bah c'est mon avis et ses
ligaments ont été réchauffée par les uv
bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]
là
est-ce que vous avez une chute à tibet
nature et notre consultative ou pour
l'engagement et pour le popotin 3,3
d'accord qui l'a mené dans ces colonies
clim oui ou non en régie est ce qu'une
ya toujours quelqu'un en régie les nous
alors oui mais on n'a pas le truc et
m'écoutais je vais le dire moi même
c'est non pour la vous votez tout de
suite pour le deuxième candidat
ça monte crescendo pour moi le deuxième
moins bon danseur de tpm pays bas où une
femme à autre chez les belles elle est
intelligente
là vous vous dites tous c'est bien sûr
vous dites il ya quelqu'un de cannes
isabelle maury c'est isabelle qui verra
plus à l'heure mais pour l'instant c'est
géraldine m'a dit
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
accès ne cache pas qu'elle a tout donné
alors on a le voc est ce qu est la mieux
danser que lenny l'aîné kim est un
garçon lenny qui me choque tiff
géraldine maillet non à 70 avec bercy
vous êtes donc toujours champion les
ducs avant battre l'aîné kim mettez-vous
d'ailleurs de l'autre côté de valérie
bénaïm non pas vous laisser les losers
attention troisième nom celui que je
considère comme le troisième moins bons
danseurs de tpm p1 c'est bien sûr
quelqu'un qui peut danser qui peut faire
la toupie avec son nez 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
le monde
[Applaudissements]
tél
emile et moi je suis ami on vous a même
souri dans le suis entraîné pendant six
ans je ne suis pas qu'il devait lire une
salle pour les progrès effectués - ça
c'est votre meilleure note pour
l'instant exactement est-ce qu'il a
mieux lancé que lenny kim gilles verdez
toujours bon soixante dix huit pour toi
non attention pour l'instant les nids tu
es toujours chanté ce quasi le public
qui va t'en c'est chez ce n'est pas
l'aspect capacité à ok et oui maintenant
on est en direct ça tombe à tout le
monde cinéma goût d'antan celle ci
ferait alors d'accueillir le quatrième
mois bon danseur ça monte crescendo
il est prêt je regarde si les prêts à
huy ah oui et danse beaucoup en boîte de
nuit
ah ah et bien sûr jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
montrer quoi le pôle emploi c'est là
c'est là bas merci jean michel merle à
notre consultative de valérie bénaïm sur
ma vie anna allez on y va
et chez vous est ce que jean michel
maire d'abord votre notre coo chez tati
alors je mets un système non non je
n'essaye l'innovation au sol elle est
pourrie il a failli se prendre
l'ensemble des pros des barbares acheté
chez vous très élégant sans franchement
alors est ce que jean michel mr a battu
dénis qui met ce qu'il a mieux dans ces
noms sur son club pour cent mais c'est
pas mal
arrivé par hasard
[Applaudissements]
attention on va rentrer non seulement
les quatre meilleurs danseurs
à redon du rock dur et c'est une
adversaire redoutable
elle a dansé avec les plus gros puisque
elle dansait déjà dans les grottes de
lascaux non elle a gagné danse avec les
silex
elle est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial confient qu'ils sont
toujours là
c'est le pipe band et je vous signale gp
bordé oui vous avez au moins un point
commun avec jean-michel et franchement
vous avez dansé ouais j'ai jamais
l'échiné comme ça déchaînés alors
attention bd live lounge insulte à tous
ceux qu'elle était déchaîné un set 7
points ce n'est pas trop fatigué et ben
10 ap quand même les médecins d'anciens
la vue là je sens que ça qui est ça peut
bouger les nids bon sortu est celui qui
a le mieux dans ces bons est ce qui
s'appelle niveau ce qui a mieux lancé
que les knicks
m
[Applaudissements]
wim van est sûre ces vitesses qui se
passe des choses ici un croyant il se
passe des choses incroyables m'a dit tu
passes du côté des losers voulaient
marcher sur les traces en équipe là on
est con on dirait une application avec
des gars quand tu me diras isabelle ti
la nouvelle championne attention on
rentre dans les trois meilleurs danseurs
ok on est connu non lourds va accueillir
celui qui danse comme ils pêchent au
bond très souvent il a répété en loge
il a répété en loge ah oui c'est
généralement un drame quand il répète
maxime gedi
[Applaudissements]
ouais
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sylla
[Musique]
la rigueur
[Applaudissements]
les loups jo et qu'on fasse un tamada
police à bo pour maxime gay nous n'avons
pas très bien à part la musique qui se
trouvait vraiment répond très bien aux
britanniques de la fin des années 90 qui
a vu sa série sur france 2 avec l'onera
la foule et je te le dis c'est toi qui
choisis
oui c'était ripoull mais toi tu as fait
une prestation exceptionnelle en
réchauffant spectateurs ont beaucoup
aimé excuse moi je voudrais enfin trouvé
sa voie ce que je dis mais pas faux si
vous avez à trouver elle va les voir
emilia ton rap derrière way attention
vers bien pour moi est-ce que tu as
mieux danser qu isabelle morini-bosc
aulas j'appelle que le meilleur danseur
ce soir allez allez allez vous fera une
chorégraphie énormissime avec beaucoup
de danseurs demain une troupe de
danseurs dédié qu'à sa petite personne
ça c'est bien c'est parti ah oui vous
avez toujours aimé les loosers de la
bande
il reste deux danseurs de danseurs ils
atteignent il a gagné le dernier
concours de danse et pourtant la danse
n'est pas son fort bah si j'ose dire il
pète la forme manoir oui même enlevé la
forme
bon ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
ouais
la donner
là
la bbc péter vann là est une cascade
c'était une cascade
ah c'est pas ben ça va attention base à
gatineau consultative bien côté droit
des malades consultative il ya de
l'engagement il ya de la folie
il ya de la cascade et de la roulade 9,6
vous dire c'est le keep up athlé dit kim
en danse ça n'est ni kim avait battu
jean michel maire gilles verdez
géraldine maillet bernard montiel il
s'est fait battre par mamie tango
isabelle morini-bosc ensuite et ce
garçon il a détrôné le fils de stéphane
bern
oui quoi non rien est-ce que castaldi va
être le nouveau meilleur danseur avant
d'accueillir notre dernière dans ce fait
vous singh et son valet je suis devant
un dilemme c'est sûr je suis dans un
dilemme et je suis devant un suspense
hitchcockien
car dans un instant la dernière danseuse
sera celle avec qui il a partagé d ur
des jours et des nuits et la dernière
danseuse est ce qu'elle va détrôner son
petit amoureux fils de stéphane bern lui
qu'on appelle dans le métier stéphane
bern jouer demain accueillir la dernière
danseuse
donnez-moi avait donné moins d'eau
donnez moi un vélib les vélos vélib
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on notera qu'à
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
mais pour tout le monde
comment ça on était sur le concours de
danse exact maxime gainey était le
danseur numéro 1 est ce que kelly l'a
détrôné si kelly vous l'avait détrônée
c'est vous qui ferait la chorégraphie
accompagnés de danseurs du monde entier
demain quand je dis du monde entier
c'est paris petite couronne une
chorégraphie que vous travaillerez
j'adorerais
vous adorerez ouais ouais oui
[Applaudissements]
le concours de danse
celui qui a détrôné les nids kim celui
qui sera demain sur scène au casino de
tpm puis sait où et me dire dans
l'oreille rapidement qui sait
le grand gagnant est sachez que dans son
prénom il y a un peu maxime qui dit ça
shake de son prénom
il n'y a pas deux aides c'est cali
[Applaudissements]
on verra